on a beaucoup étudié pour cet examen là
ça englobe vraiment les trois années
d'études ces trois étudiantes ont été
choquées de voir le résultat à l'examen
de l'Ordre des infirmiers et infirmières
du Québec
elle travaille déjà dans des hôpitaux
comme CP candidate à l'exercice de la
profession des firmières
au milieu on peut soigner des patients
on a 8 9 10 12 passés en charge on
travaille avec des infirmières
auxiliaires puis d'un coup on peut pas
être infirmière j'ai eu des bonnes notes
toute mon parcours j'ai réussi tous mes
stages et puis de voir cette note là
c'est comme un gros échec c'est comme un
frein dans le fond dans mon rêve un peu
exercice donc le premier c'est pour
obtenir le brevet d'infirmière les
étudiantes doivent atteindre 55% à
l'examen obligatoire de Loïc cette année
près de la moitié des futurs infirmières
ont échoué le test à notre avis la
pandémie a joué un rôle important le
taux de réussite est de seulement
51,4 % au dernier examen de septembre
c'est la croix qui a été la plus
contrainte au niveau de ses études faire
des cours à distance les l'accès au
laboratoire l'accès au milieu de stage a
été perturbé à cause de la pandémie et
ça c'est certain que ça pose un défi
pour les personnes aux études au niveau
des apprentissages
propose deux sessions d'examens par
année avant la pandémie en 2019 les taux
de réussite étaient de 73 et 91%.
pourtant lors du premier examen de 2022
le taux était de 71% au premier tour
pour les personnes à l'extérieur du
Québec le taux a dégringolé il est passé
de 53% au début de 2022 à moins de 20%
britannique ne croit pas que la pandémie
soit en cause moi personnellement je
pense pas que ça le atteint
nécessairement nos compétences et ça
nous a brimés de quoi que ce soit pour
Émilie il y a urgence de revoir
l'évaluation de l'ordre des choix de
réponse à son examen c'est pas ça qui
fait nous des personnes compétentes sur
le terrain en pratique pendant que
Québec investit pour embaucher les 28000
infirmières manquantes d'ici les cinq
prochaines années des centaines d'entre
elles qui ont échoué le test ne seront
pas en poste de manière autonome cet
hiver Loïc rappelle que sa mission est
de protéger le public mais le manque de
personnel pourrait la forcer à revoir
ses évaluations
ici Marie-Josée paquet de Comores au
Canada Montréal